my brother 遊びに来てるんですけども僕は弟思いなんですよ
聞いたことないって女ことないだろっていうけど弟なよあーー遊びに行ってるんです
けどもちょっとハト蛯名としてあげようと思いました金もやっぱり大学てつまらない
日常にうんざり飽き飽きしてると思うんですよ
一言も言ってないけどそんな彼の日常くいくい分あるために今回はこちら構想
ブドリでを買ってみました高速取りでなんて日常的に使うことはまずないと思うんで
これでちょっと彼が実をブチ壊してやろうかと思いまして
どんぐらい改定すんだろうね回転数はあぁそうじゃないなら書いパワー
あこうするよう1200回転だ4200回転ってことはどういうこと1秒4前に行っ
回転
バケモンじゃないかそんなに回転するか1分が1分で4200開示で
でこそは一部70回てんだあ
はや1秒にならず書いても十分ずいぶん十分すごいそれだけじゃ部分がやってどんな
からだろう
ああああああ
だからこれやばいな気がする速さだこれ
[笑い]
ハロ誘致余ってるそこあぶねえなあゆずこそを回転させてみましょう
ダメならばジャズこそゆずごしょうが開店できない
ティッシュつけたらすっごい扇風機謎ねー
[笑い]
[音楽]
うわぁ一緒っていう古いなマニュアルをご覧いただいた通り威力が強かったと思います
死んで今回これを受けどのように弟方心添えちょい立てて子連れてるのか
こちらです車本なのでございますそのスピードを出すとこう
サポーターはができるわけですよほらどんなばどんどんできる子スピード化ゲート
シャボン玉が出るんですよ
5原理を利用して例えばドリルの先端にくっつけますとこれで回すと大ねー
これは男のこのこんなボロ
ねマジでわりとうまくいっ
[音楽]
いいんじゃないここの先端にシャボンだろうなこのゼルこれをつけて回転させると
このに給料してシャボン玉が頼りでますついて今回
とタイ料理この者こんなもう買ってきたので今度経済の部分だけをたくさんこのドリル
の先端に付けて音が入った瞬間にこれが回転しだして回転し次でも平野連れが
シャボン玉たら気になってたぶんすごい jp
日常の幸せな気持ちになれると思うので一瞬で円了のサポートも作れるつを高速回転ば
シーンを作っていこうと思います未来子
質量をつけるだけつけてみ荘
tee
th
い
持っていた
ええええええ
これぞドリルの回転力を生かしたちょっ高速シャボン玉製造機ですこれであとはな
ちゃんと向きを揃えちゃんとシャボン玉が出る方向で合わせて回転すれば間違いなくた
巡査盆玉が出ると思われます
いい感じ館図
[拍手]
ファンであるやるありで ok で使い時で完成したのでこれの1本ずつ電車ボートば
液をしっかり付けてマックを張ってその状態で弟が入ってきた瞬間に僕はこれを回し
ますそちらこぺあつーかシャボン玉だけどトーター萌えが僕も笑顔ハッピーな兄弟が
見れるでございますで刺す事と読んでみましょう
me
まあ
うそっ
[音楽]
いいえいます
でた者の玉ずっと
どれくらいそれぞれ
捕まったら官能さ感動しさ
結構怖かった